good morning John I have been on the
internet for a long time now and I've
also watched a lot of other people be on
the internet for a long time and it
seems like though I appreciate constant
calls to oh God oh God just please go
touch some grass we are going to all
continue being on the internet despite
the fact that we are not particularly
good at it so since we can't stop the
only choice we have is to get better at
it and thus I would like to give you my
absolute number one tip to people
putting their thoughts on the internet
whether it's a tweet to your 200
followers or a YouTube video to 2
million a piece of understanding that
absolutely every early Creator including
myself gets wrong and that I have seen
result in the end of a bunch of careers
before it was time for them to end
listen carefully listen closely
if you make something that reaches a
very large number of people you will
hear every single conceivable thought
reaction and opinion that a human person
in our culture could have
the Axiom of virality the larger the
reach of your content the larger the
pool of takes this is just a statistical
fact any piece of content has a
potential pool of thousands of reactions
people could have to it but some of them
are extremely uncommon now the most
common ones are probably the ones that
you will see first though of course
there's always a chance that you'll get
an uncommon one first which would be
great if they were Pokemon cards but
they're not the uncommon ones often have
two very bizarre attributes first they
are more likely to be silly and wrong
and thus they should be ignored and
second they are more likely to shock you
and others and so they are harder to
ignore and so people reply to them and
they engage with them which many modern
algorithms see as increasing engagement
increasing the time you're spending on
the platform and thus the less common
worse opinions are often intentionally
promoted but the uncommon opinion does
not deserve to be the center of
attention because it is far outside of
the center of opinion if it weren't it
would not have been so shocking
the only reason it even exists is
because the piece of content in question
reached so many people that it is not
only likely but guaranteed to receive
extremely weird takes in my opinion and
there are other opinions here but in my
opinion as a person who's been doing
this for a long time the only thing to
do with those bizarre takes is to see
them as Fringe weirdness and when we see
them think oh that one's weird like it
were a particularly ugly frog some
reactions are impossible not to harp on
not to be disturbed by even and the pool
of potential takes is different for
different creators which makes this job
harder for certain kinds of people if I
had to deal with half of what I've seen
some of my friends who are women or
black people deal with I would just have
quit I would not do this anymore but I
don't know how to stop the takes from
coming I only know that the takes will
come so if you can find a way to have
them matter less or not at all you
should because if you have a piece of
content that goes very viral and you
find yourself astounded by some of the
takes it receives remember people are
very weird you know this you've met them
if your Tweet reached 10 million people
you will see every possible confusion
every possible bad faith interpretation
every single possible reaction and the
fact that the reaction exists doesn't
mean it should matter to you we're not
designed to be good at receiving
reactions of a crowd of tens of millions
of people and figuring out how to
classify some things as like oh God just
go touch some grass I'm not going to pay
attention to you takes and the ones that
are legitimate useful criticism that I
should be paying attention to is
honestly possibly the hardest part of
this job I've been doing it for a very
long time and I'm still working at
getting better at it but one thing I can
say to every Creator out there the mere
fact that a take exists does not mean
that it is worthy of even one neuron of
your brain focusing on it John I'll see
you on Tuesday thanks